bassam dan politologue et spécialiste du
moyen-orient il est l'invité de la
matinale de lille et de 40 flec bassam
dames bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors pour commencer peut-être
votre réaction sur le traitement
médiatique de ces années de guerre ainsi
rit on parlait il ya quelques instants
une couverture médiatique parcellaire
avec des rhétoriques
antigouvernementales quel est votre
regard à vous sur ce traitement
médiatique à ce traitement médiatique
comme votre apport l'a démontré c'est un
tissu de mensonges
il avait pour but de soutenir la
politique du gouvernement français et
son interventionnisme dans un dossier
qui ne le concernait pas à sa robe en
daim hollande fabius le drian qui est
toujours google en tout ça ce sont des
mensonges mais ce qui est étonnant c'est
que les américains eux mêmes en sont
revenus et ont rectifié le tir avec leur
quotidien leurs médias mais toujours pas
la france
sheila une exception française à ajouter
à la liste des exceptions de notre
france décadente je dirai quand je dis
ça par amour pour mon pays la france
on va parler justement de la france de
la position de la france on va revenir
au début de l'année 2011
on a le sentiment en tout cas vu d'ici
que tous les ingrédients sont réunis
pour que la syrie vivent ce qu'on a
appelé ici un printemps arabe
on dit que bachar al assad va tomber en
quelques semaines dix ans après il est
toujours là comment est ce que vous le
comprenez vous l'expliquer alors d'abord
permettez boîte de rectifier pour moi il
n'y a pas de printemps arabe
il ya un printemps américain parce que
dès septembre 2011
la cia avec l'arabie séoudite avait
dessiné le plan de ce qu'on appelle
timbers sycomore
qui consistait à renverser assad et il
ya eu des centaines de milliards de
dollars utilisés à ce dessein mais le
peuple syrien a résisté
donc cette histoire de dire que c'est
pacifique tout ça est complètement faux
a bien avant les événements les manifs
comme on dit pacifique
il y a eu des attaques des symboles du
pouvoir que ce soit à lattaquié que ce
soit dallas il y a eu des morts il ya eu
des éléments de sécurité qui ont été
assassinés
tout ça est une fable qui a été colporté
par leurs médias à l'époque pour
soutenir notre gouvernement qui a eu la
grande erreur qui a commis la grave
erreur de reconnaître l'opposition
syrienne essentiellement islamistes et j
analystes comme seul et unique
représentant du peuple syrien
c'est du n'importe quoi en tout cas
après 10 ans hier est une réalité c'est
la situation humanitaire qui est
catastrophique
quelles sont les urgences aujourd'hui
pour la population syrienne
vous savez c'est très dramatique ce qui
se passe alors on me dit mais pourquoi
la syrie ne se reconstruit pas assez
tout simplement l'objet dès le départ
était de détruire ce pays laïc et bien
il n'y a aucune raison de lui permettre
à nouveau de se relever
d'où les sanctions sanctions il humaine
c'est un crime contre l'humanité et
évidemment les réfugiés sans une carte
entre les mains des gouvernements ou des
pays qui les ont accueillis tout
simplement pour faire pression sur
l'europe et soutirer de l'argent à
l'europe voire la politique d'erdogan en
turquie en jordanie ainsi de suite
bachar el-assad franchement
et un héros non seulement pour son
peuple
mais pour le monde arabe et le monde
musulman et même le diamant il n'a
jamais suivi le diktat américain il n'a
pas oublié les chine 1 voilà
et il a et jouit d'une popularité
immense dans le monde arabo musulman
d'un point de vue militaire les
terroristes poursuivent encore leurs
opérations à la frontière irako syrienne
cette organisation était islamique
finalement personne en 7 10 en guerre
n'a vu l'ampleur finalement de son
arrivée c'est à dire que la coalition
occidentale a prétendu être là-bas pour
combattre l'état islamique entièrement
faux ils sont là bas ils sont restés des
années sans rien faire jusqu'à l'arrivée
et l'intervention efficace des russes
alors ils sont là-bas pour démanteler la
syrie
et pour piller son pétrole ça c'est alès
de leurs phrases tout le monde le sait
maintenant pour ce qui est de de la
province d'idlib
chaque fois que l'armée syrienne a voulu
débarrasser le monde
oui je dis bien le monde de ces
terroristes parce que jusqu'à dont la
sphère samuel pâtit 1
le dernier contact était avec la
province d'idlib 1 chaque fois qu'on a
voulu nettoyer sans rudy a non seulement
il ya les civils
rien alors que la coalition nettoie
heaslip d'une manière un qu'ils se
retroussent les manches et qui nous
montrent de quoi ils sont capables
non tout ça franchement c c'est
contraire à toute logique au bon sens au
droit des peuples c'est du n'importe
quoi franchement dans tous les diables
pour conclure en quelques mots on pense
aussi à la limite quand il y à une
intervention occidentale bien derrière
souvent c'est le désastre c'est vrai
c'est vrai on bombarde à tout bout de
champ avec du mensonge les américains
les grands spécialistes disent qu'il n'y
a jamais eu de chimiques en syrie en
tout cas on l'imputent haut à l'armée
syrienne alors que l'armée syrienne à
l'époque en 2000
pour ce qui est de l'art ou pas été loin
du lieu
mais personne personne n'écoute la
vérité on continue le mensonge c'est
grave c'est vraiment grave pour nos
médias qui après on vous parle de la
liberté de l'expression
moi je veux bien qu'on me montre et se
retrouve cette liberté d'expression
chaque fois qu'on parle de la syrie il
n'y a jamais quelqu'un qui puisse parler
du côté je me dire de damas d'expliquer
de voir autrement les choses c'est pas
normal c'est pas normal on nous invite
des gens soi disant expert de la syrie
ils sont experts de rien du tout ce sont
des éditorialistes qui sont spécialistes
de tout et de rien en tous les cas vous
avez pu exprimer dans la matinale de rtl
france un autre point de vue ce matin
merci à vous bassam thann et d'avoir
répondu à notre question je le rappelle
vous êtes politologue spécialiste du
moyen-orient